Moscow has a new champion was sword and
cross in hand
Vladimir keeps watch over the Russian
capital Vladimir Putin said the new
monument to his namesake and Russia's
founding father should serve as a
reminder for Russians to rally together
to stave off threats from abroad today
our duty is to jointly oppose modern
challenges and threats relying on our
spiritual legacy priceless traditions of
unity and accord to move forward experts
say it's the latest example of
religiously infused pro-military
nationalism that has become the hallmark
of Russian political discourse thanks in
part to Kremlin back TV coverage of the
war in Syria viewers rarely see the
atrocities allegedly carried out by
forces loyal to Russia's Ally Syrian
President Bashar al-assad instead they
are treated to patriotic footage of
Russian military prowess which is up
until claims gay propaganda its anti
Western propaganda anti-ukrainian
propaganda and it's creating fear that a
major war could soon break out and this
angst is unifying people divorce
understanding just written the
conciliatory approach story but it's not
unifying everyone behind the Kremlin
away from the official Unity Day
celebrations and under heavy guard
far-right protesters and liberal
opposition groups have come together to
demand that the Russian government
resign however there is little sign of
dissent at the Kremlin sponsored
festivities opinion surveys indicate
there is a growing apprehension among
Russians that Moscow's military
adventures could drag the country into a
larger military conflict but that
doesn't seem to have hurt glad Amir
Putin's popularity here we support his
policies and want to emphasize that our
strength lies in unity not just you
Jesus
at least for today Moscow is once again
showing the world how it wants to be
seen as a unified people in the face of
international isolation a healthy dose
of national pride is hardly caused or
concern but in the face of increasingly
martial rhetoric some observers here in
Moscow fear the further Russians rally
around the policies of Vladimir Putin
the further away they drift from their
European neighbors